and thanks for your patience while we
got set up um
so it's sunday and a lot of texans are
at church
and you're here with me at pi data and
we're going to talk about death so
welcome
i this i think this is a sign
yeah this is a sign
okay great so that's not entirely true
death is really just a metaphor here
what i'm really going to talk about is
the
intense fear
that individuals and organizations
across many sectors academia
government journalism even private
corporations
have about sharing their data
i'm talking about a fear of losing power
fear of becoming irrelevant fear of
losing control fear of the unknown
maybe even fear of having your
professional identity challenged and
these sound like big talk topics but
these are some of the biggest fears we
have as humans
and then i'm going to talk a little bit
about
how we can use well-defined
communication strategies drawn from
community builders and experts who
specialize in end of life communication
to help people in our organizations deal
with some of the big shifts in culture
that are often necessary to get data out
in the open
so connecting death and open data might
seem like an enormous leap to you
but i've been thinking about it for a
couple of years now and i'm really eager
to explore the idea with you today
and i'll start by walking you through
how i got there
but first
i'm dana bauer
and despite the tenor of this talk i'm a
fairly light hearted person
and i delight in working with open
source
projects open source communities this is
a picture of me preparing to lead a
balloon mapping workshop
with an open science group called the
public lab
my current work is as a developer
advocate at rackspace where i focus on
supporting and serving open source
projects and open communities
so i'm not an expert in end-of-life care
or communications theory and i'm not a
psychologist
but i do have quite a bit of experience
working in the open data movement and
i've been organizing and leading open
source communities for several years now
which means of course
that i have experience having difficult
conversations
both technical and non-technical
conversations because we all know that
code is easy and people are hard
so what do i mean by open data and and
what are the connections between open
data and the big data that many of you
at this conference work with
this particular diagram is from a book
called open data now by joel gurin
and here's his basic description of what
open data is
it's accessible public data that people
companies organizations
can use
to make data-driven decisions
analyze new patterns and trends solve
complex problems
and launch new ventures
some of the basic features of open data
must be publicly available for anyone to
use
must be licensed in a way that allows
for its reuse should be relatively easy
to use
although of course there are different
gradations of openness
there's a general agreement that open
data should be free of charge or cost
just a minimal amount
some of you might quibble with these
definitions but i think it's a useful
place to start
i find the focus on open government here
in this diagram an interesting one and i
could easily imagine redrawing this to
take a look at the intersection between
open data and open science
oops
so first let's look at some of these
intersections
big data that's not open data
often this is data collected about
consumers meant to be used or resold for
marketing purposes
but this could also include data from
the nsa
not open data but of course we've all
seen some of it
which could mean that the phrase data
will find a way is true
and there are different kinds of open
data
that come from small local governments
data about city parks
uh socioeconomic data at the state level
this is the kind of small to medium data
that i like to work with and that i'm
most familiar with this is the kind of
data that's great fodder for civic
hackers
and i considered giving a talk called in
in defense of small to medium data at
this big data conference
and there are lots of other
intersections here that are interesting
to explore
some open data that's not necessarily
governmental data so
human genome project or
large astronomical data sets perhaps
these were produced with government
funding
but they're not government data per se
and then the trifecta
open government data big data open data
and you can think of something like the
census
falling into that particular category or
weather data perhaps
we can't talk about open data without
giving a shout out to some of the
hard-working organizations that help
facilitate the opening of data across
many areas and here are just a few i
should have included num focus perhaps
and they need your support
okay so let me back you up and tell you
an open data story
a couple of years ago when i was working
as a freelancer i had an interesting gig
with a small foundation that collected
and preserved several centuries worth of
books
papers lab journals and photographs from
scientists and engineers
some of this was digitized but most of
it wasn't and only a portion of it was
accessible or searchable on the
foundation's website and in its museum
the photo here is of archives at the
vatican it's not from the foundations
collection i just thought it might be
cool to imagine an api or something for
the vatican's archives
so the folks from the foundation who
approached me for this project were
really energetic and connected to the
growing community of digital humanities
they wanted to open up as much data as
possible from the collections
they wanted to see the foundation's
members the civic hacking community the
digital humanities community scientists
and educators create amazing
visualizations with their data
and that vision was really inspiring and
as a science nerd and former science
writer i was really sold on the project
however when i began
to dig in
i realized quickly
that the task of helping the foundation
share its data
was more of a people problem than a
technology problem
to be fair there were certain
interesting technical challenges
involved in unlocking the data from the
very expensive and proprietary database
software that the foundation was already
using but for the most part the problem
had to do with the culture of the
organization
there were some folks in the foundation
who weren't so interested in sharing
this data
their concerns were about
upsetting some of the benefactors and
companies on the board of the foundation
but there was also something else
fear that opening up the archives and
making the data accessible
would somehow render the foundation
irrelevant
the foundation wasn't protecting and
guarding the collection what was its
purpose
the caption here doesn't quite reflect
the situation no one at the foundation
was actually charging visitors to
explore the data
i can't say the same for the vendor that
sold that database software to the
foundation they were clearly ripping
people off
okay so i'm a huge fan of collaboration
and i asked my friends from the action
mill a philadelphia based design firm to
help me lead a brainstorming workshop at
the foundation in hopes that we would
spark a conversation about open data and
get them moving on the right path
the action mill made up of these fine
people jethro heiko nick chilin rob
piegler and georgia guthrie
focuses on human-centered design and a
big interest of theirs is helping
individuals teams
and companies conduct meaningful
effective work
they also specialize in helping
organizations through times of great
change
and the path to great change really
requires an ability to facilitate
difficult discussions often emotionally
charged discussions
the actionable folks are experts at that
so they were great partners for that
project
and this is what we ended up doing for
the foundation we facilitated a series
of discussions to help them find common
ground and prepare the organization for
making that big shift to further opening
the archives
so
while we were putting together
these workshops and discussions with the
foundation
the action mill team was working on a
new project to help people with
end-of-life
conversations the project was a game
called my gift of grace
and it's designed to help families
medical professionals counselors help
people learn how to live well and die
well and have discussions about living
well and dying well
and to come to grips with their fears of
death fear of the unknown fear of the
end of what we've always known
they told me about the project
and they used some of those same
techniques in the game to facilitate the
discussions in our workshop with the
foundation
and that's when the parallel between
fear of death and fear of opening data
first struck me
it's probably not a coincidence that
this came to me after several sleepless
days and nights of frantically finishing
freelance projects
i like to call the night before a big
deadline the dark night of the soul
this fear of change wasn't entirely new
to me
before i had this freelancing job i
worked for an organization
that did a lot of mapping and geospatial
projects and i spent several years at
that firm extracting data and
legislative boundaries
maps from local state and federal
governments from around the world
and i worked with a team to build a
database and an api
to make that data readily available to
non-profits
but i had to deal with a fair amount of
fear and suspicion to get the data
my team and i would often have to call
government offices
ask them beg them for their data
and in many cases there was one person
who was the gatekeeper
he usually worked alone perhaps in a
basement office forever shackled to
proprietary gis software from a company
that shall not be named
this person was clearly lonely and he
often kept me on the phone wanting to
talk data and the peculiarities of the
software that dominated his life
he was clearly a person who felt a
little isolated and unappreciated but
was also fiercely protective of his role
as the gatekeeper of the data
i ended up calling these phone calls and
chats gis therapy
but we were successful
we built a massive database
and some of that data in part became the
seed for the first version of open data
philly the city of philadelphia's open
data portal launched in 2010
i was involved in the first version of
this portal portal and the version you
see here was redesigned recently and
it's become the lovely face of a
thriving community of open data
enthusiasts and civic hackers in
philadelphia
but the city's journey to open data was
hard one
and change agents and city government
are still having hard conversations with
folks who are afraid of what open means
and her mark head one of those change
agents
mark is kind of a superman character a
little bit of clark kent by day a little
bit of superman at civic events at night
he's worked on the policy side of
government he's worked as a software
developer he was one of the leaders at
code for america and in 2012 he was
appointed the city of philadelphia's
first chief data officer
right away mark was put to work tasked
with implementing mayor michael nutter's
executive order
pledging greater transparency through
data releases
this open data policy called for some
big changes
make data available through an open
portal hire a chief data officer
establish working groups
get all the lawyers in the city on board
to review the efforts require each city
department to publish a catalog of its
open data
and require that that data be in an open
format a tall order
recently i talked to mark about some of
his experiences working with agencies in
the city of philadelphia
he did have good success during his 18
months as chief data officer and he was
able to get the city to release more
than 50 new data sets including crime
data police complaint data
and some property data really important
stuff but it wasn't easy
what he really encountered
was
a sense of fear in some of the
government agencies that he worked with
they expressed concern
for how releasing the data might affect
the agency but mostly the responses were
very personal
what will happen to my job
what happens to all the work that i did
will people forget about my work
a lot of people working in technology in
this particular city government saw
themselves as solution developers
they built government websites that help
people find parks learn about trash
collection days pay their water bills
they identified as people who built
these externally facing things
but open data turned that around instead
of the government employees being the
sole creators of interfaces to
government people outside of government
could take the data and do what they
wanted with it
and this scared people in government
what's my role will i become irrelevant
mark said
it was almost a lonely feeling of what
will happen to me now
he was able to get some people to think
about it differently by telling them
that they're now a facilitator a
collaborator a steward of open data and
that these roles were crucial
but the degree to which he was
successful really depended on how long
the technologist had been in government
mark left his position as chief data
officer in 2014 after hitting a very
painful road block trying to get the
city to release property tax balances
hugely important in a city with
long-standing problems with tax
delinquency and collection
mark plans to return to government
someday
to lead open data efforts in another
city
while we were talking mark pointed me to
the work of the sunlight foundation
a good government group that works hard
to get government agencies at all levels
to release their data
a couple years ago the sunlight
foundation issued a report on some of
the reasons why
government agencies and officials don't
release data
they wrote the report based on a survey
of responses that they got from folks
who work with governments open data
advocates journalists
you know even folks within government
that were trying to get their peers to
release data
here's some tidbits clean from the
report
my data is a mess and i'll look bad
it's hard it is hard
it's already public
moving too quickly is scary how will we
go back if we have to
those journalists
they're going to really mess it up for
the city
my data is so complex and magical and i
think this is something scientists might
say too if they're pressured to make
their data open
this is my absolute favorite
yeah
i'm not sure where to start with this
one
freedom of information act so
this statement alone probably made a
thousand journalists die a quick death
the old system works
hackers will do stuff to it so
interestingly enough this is an issue
within some private companies too
i ran a hackathon within a big company
and i encountered this fear of hackers
it was really interesting when a big guy
from the security team at this company
charged down to the event to talk to me
about what we were doing
people might sue us
so this is a legitimate fear this is in
part the reason why the city of
philadelphia wanted the lawyers on board
and in fact shortly after they released
their license and inspection data
the local magazine philadelphia magazine
published a data set of people whose
applications for gun permits were
rejected
those data had their name where they
worked the reason for the rejection and
their addresses
and the city yanked that back really
quickly
it's public data
maybe it should be open
but
this is why humans are involved we have
to make good decisions i don't think the
city was sued about that
so this is probably true for a lot of
corporate data although we could
probably talk about some of the wisdom
in that and there are also cases where
data are required to be private hipaa
for example
it's not my job
my incentives are not to make it open
i'm not rewarded
what will happen to my job will my role
change if we're suddenly releasing the
data to the public
so you can probably sense that behind a
lot of these concerns is fear
and really when i talked to mark i got
the sense that in some of the government
officials he worked with there was this
existential crisis
so
for academic researchers especially in
the sciences you can imagine that many
of these fears are the same but there's
one question that looms larger than the
others
and this is probably hardest on
idealistic young scientists
looking for tenure
you know many of them are savvy about
open data practices and open source
tools like python for working with their
data they want to share it but they're
constrained by a system that doesn't
reward it
so i know many of you are from a science
background i want to talk a little bit
about open science and i'd like you to
meet christie balai
an ecologist postdoc at michigan state
university and a blogger
she's very active in the open science
and open access communities and she's an
instructor with software carpentry and
data carpentry and that's how i met her
we taught a workshop together at the
university of michigan to get scientists
up to speed on data management coding
sql inversion control
christie writes a lot about her work on
her blog and she shares her experiences
generously
one of my favorite posts of hers is baby
steps for the open
curious here are some of the things that
she's heard in her community
interestingly you hear the scoop part
from journalists too
fear that someone will take your idea if
you share your code
pre-prince are you insane
so i i'm not an academic i'm going to
take christie's word on this
so these are some of the fears that
she's hearing her colleagues talk about
i know
open science is is not the same as open
data but i think the discussion is kind
of the same and some of the concerns are
the same
so christy likes to say that there's a
movement in the open so science
communities to do better science by
sharing data and code
it makes sense it's easy to reproduce
someone's research if you have access to
their data and the tools they use for
their analysis
and reproducibility is the key to good
science
christie and others like her as a
community builder you know if she does
even if she doesn't see herself that way
and i've learned a lot about what's
happening in this community just from
chatter in the software carpentry
community and on twitter
where people are sharing their deepest
desires for what practicing open science
in their communities could be like
i like this one expressing gratitude
also at some point culture change and
academia is coming and i'm sure that
people like christie balai will be
leading it
so what can we do to help people conquer
their fears and share their data
i think first this is the most important
thing to remember people are hard
and they need lots of support and
reassurance
this is not a bit touchy-feely
maybe but show me a good technologist
who hasn't been vulnerable at some point
in their career
people are hard collaborating with
people is messy
people are hard in government this is
probably one of my favorite quotes from
my conversation with mark
he's a technologist he's a great
developer but he spent most of his time
hand-holding working with people
listening to their fears
people are hired in academia
this is a card that i recently gave to
one of my dear friends who's finishing
up her phd
if you can't read it it says
i'm sorry you cried in front of your
advisor
technology is complicated code is
complicated data is complex people are
harder than all of this
and i just wanted to slip into baymax
hero
photo
people are hard in big companies too
and this is the the one sticker
that we made on my team that everyone
loves the most and i think it really
captures the way we operate in our in
our team in our company we're big
supporters of open source
we know that it's messy and hard
but we work at it a lot we talk about it
a lot my team leader rackspace an
amazing guy named jesse noller would
probably be so happy if we hugged it out
after every code review and technical
team meeting
that's only if we let him
okay so i want to bring this back to
death
let's go back to our friends from the
action mill
their game my gift of grace was so
widely popular
among all different age groups that they
shifted the focus of their entire
company they renamed their group the
common practice
and they started centering all of their
design and conversation efforts
on end-of-life communication
groups of all ages and backgrounds found
these conversations extremely useful for
dealing with many different kinds of
personal and organizational change
so
drawing on the work of psychologists
medical professionals and communication
experts the team at common practice
wrote a weight paper
and talked about their experiences
putting into practice a framework for
organizing ideas around end-of-life
conversations
they talked a lot about multiple goals
theory in this white paper
and here's where i'm reaching way
outside my area of expertise and the
threat of my talk might get a little
thin
but in the spirit of conquering our
fears i'm going to plow ahead
so in short multiple goals theory is
based on this idea that people engage in
communication in order to achieve
multiple often conflicting goals
research in this area has revealed that
a variety of possible there are a
variety of possible goals that people
are trying to achieve in conversation
but three types of goals appear in
conversations on almost any topic
task relational and identity
the task goals are easy the first to
come to mind when thinking about
communication these are the goals that
come to the surface they're stated
quickly and easily and sometimes they
are directives
so if we could imagine a task related
goal in the open data world it's great
let's get started let's share your data
with the public
the relational goals are less obvious
these are meant to change or reinforce
the connection one person has with
another
you might
look at reconciling differences or
maintaining connections or affirming
bonds so here's this idea that we're
going to do it together
releasing this data is for the greater
good identity goals are the hardest to
understand and the hardest to uncover
during conversations they're about
managing impressions both of the speaker
and the listener and this includes
things like preserving autonomy
maintaining dignity negotiating roles
these are really hard things to get at
in a conversation
and they're offering embarrassing for
people to talk about
one thing that mark said during our
conversation is that
he was really trying a little too hard
to convince people that the idea of open
data was for the greater good
really
he should have been focusing a little
bit more on their individual fears
so
my friends at the common practice
started taking this on the road
it's great to talk about theory it's
great to write white papers but where
they really excelled was running
workshops
with lots of different groups
even some technology companies
getting people learning how to have
difficult conversations a lot of these
focused on mortality but not all of them
and the game and a lot of the
conversations started with questions
like this
which might be a little scary for a
20-something or 30-something or
40-something they really get you
thinking about what you want to achieve
in life what's most important to you
and should i really be paying attention
to all these things that i'm afraid of
i added that one
this is another another
part of the workshop exercise
people found incredibly useful
think of the way that you want to be
remembered really kind of strips away a
lot of the fears and baggage that we
carry even in our work lives
another part of the project was to
really get people discussing what they
valued
what their fears were getting them all
out on the table and in the workplace
this is kind of a scary thing
interestingly vulnerability is kind of a
buzzword in corporate america and i'm a
little skeptical
but i think in this particular case if
you're working with an open source
community if you're working with a
community that wants to go in that
direction
this could be really useful
so what am i suggesting here
that we all have therapy in our
workplaces that we all run workshops
that are very touchy-feely no not not
really but i think the key is to start
with an identity goal especially if
you're trying to convince
people in your community to share their
data and open their data
i'm a firm believer that community
building can get us moving in the right
direction this is why so many open
source software projects have thriving
helpful supportive communities around
them
people like mark
people like christy people like the
designers of the common practice
obviously in many cases
it's going to take institutional change
to release data universities governments
big companies with big organizations
it's hard to steer a ship in a new
direction
so i want to end here
when i first shared the idea of this
talk with a colleague i gave them the
title
death and open data he said death and
open data
i'm intrigued but i'm not sure i
understand you mean like death and taxes
and that's not quite what i meant but i
liked where he was going
maybe open data is inevitable and that
might be a dream
but this is a really exciting time to be
working with open data in government
it's an exciting time to be working with
open data in the sciences in journalism
and it's an exciting time to be part of
a big company like the one i work for
where new innovations are being built on
top of open source cold code fed
upstream
and it's all part of a thriving living
breathing
ecosystem
thank you